the mystery is surrounding the deaths of
three Americans at sister resorts and
the Dominican Republican is deepening
this morning after the release of new
autopsy results a Pennsylvania woman and
a Maryland couple died at Baia príncipe
hotels in the last two weeks CTM
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
here at jurika good morning good morning
what do these autopsies show well we
have these new results and there's still
a lot of questions but these new results
from the dominican authorities reveal
that there were some similarities and
how the americans died but the resort
insists that deaths are unrelated and is
condemning any speculation on May 25th
Miranda shop warner collapsed and died
in her hotel room at the luxury Bahia
Principe Bougainville hotel in a
statement the resort said she died of a
heart attack and had a history of heart
conditions a preliminary autopsy
indicates she died of fluid in the lungs
and respiratory failure the same thing
is indicated on the autopsy for Edward
Holmes and Cynthia day the maryland
couple was found dead in their hotel
room last week at the Gran Bahia
Principe La Romana hotel what caused the
respiratory failure is unclear and a
toxicology report is not available yet
now US tourism is a key market for the
Dominican Republic's economy in January
and February this year alone nearly
400,000 tourists from the US visited the
country the FBI is now assisting
Dominican Republic authorities in the
investigation into the three deaths the
CDC is also investigating just a very
sad story because the family wants
clarity what happened and how did
seemingly healthy people end up dead you
know while having the time of their
lives I hope they can get answers soon
because I know they keep saying it's
unrelated but it's hard as a layperson
on the outside looking and not to think
that there's some connection right and
then you've got the couple in Fiji yeah
unrelated to this but just this we all
know what's more frightening the idea
that they're not related or the idea
that they are right yeah good question
sad for the families thank you yeah very
sad